Hello and welcome to Holotalk, the internet radio broadcast for lasers and holography.
Enjoyed by listeners throughout the world.
I'm Frank Defratis, and I'll be your host for each installment, bringing you news, guests, and everything holographic.
Now, please enjoy the latest show.
Yes.
How are you?
It's Frank Defratus.
Hi, Frank.
Good.
You got my email, I take it.
Yeah, I just got it a little while ago.
I figured I'd go up and make a cup of tea and come down and get things hooked up to uh give you a call.
Okay.
Why don't you tell the listeners right away about your two shows since in case we have anybody out there that listens to the first five minutes and then cuts it off.
All right.
Uh one is um the f uh May 5th opening at the Hollow Center in Long Island City, New York, and that's called um Shelf Life.
And in that one I'm com ba combining I've got about six uh paintings and uh about six holograms.
And the holograms are all work I did uh in nineteen ninety-nine, two thousand.
Is it just across from Harper's Ferry?
Oh okay.
That little corner there.
It's the last uh stop on the mark train out of DC.
And uh that's a little show it's called the Sundance uh uh gallery.
And my sister runs it.
So um we're doing a little well it's you know, I've got about twenty paintings I'm showing there.
And it's also a celebration of my uh my father would have been a hundred years old this year and uh who was a painter as well.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're gonna we've done some little things, made a few prints of some of his paintings and my family's coming up for Ohio.
So it'll be just both those shows will be just fun.
I think I haven't uh sweated too much about either of 'em.
So I'll have links to um the Holo Center.
If you have a link to the gallery in uh Maryland.
Actually, um uh no but uh it can there's information on my webcast uh W W Mary Harmon dot com.
Mm-hmm.
And I'll have a link to your site as well.
And if anyone goes to type that in, it's H A R M A N.
That's very interesting.
If you type in H A R M O N, you get a real estate agent in Ohio.
Oh is that right?
Mary Harman, H A R M O N.
She sells.
Yeah, she sells real estate.
I did find a Harman Cemetery in Ohio.
Oh, did you?
It's H A R M A N Were you were born in Ohio, right?
I was born in Putnam County, Ohio.
That's a rural area, is that Amish country?
No, it's German.
Basically all the people there were uh German immigrants except for my father who was Flemish and he came down from Canada.
He was an immigrant worker in uh southern uh Ontario picking tobacco.
What was he doing?
I'm sorry.
He uh he was picking tobacco.
Oh tobacco in Ohio, uh, Belgium uh to southern Ontario to work in the tobacco fields.
And um and then he went down to uh basically got to Ohio uh and uh worked in the um I think it was the beats then picking beats what the immigrants did.
And ended up staying, married my mother and stayed.
So it's a yeah very, very German community.
There were a lot of kids uh who didn't speak any English at all when they started school.
The same here in Pennsylvania.
Yeah, with the Amish and Pennsylvania Dutch and German.
Yeah.
Not too far from that where I am here in Allentown.
In fact, one of the um uh during World War Two, one of our local towns was because it's all German speaking, was uh raided by another town.
Oh really?
Uh because of the of the Germans It never ends.
It never ends.
Right, yeah.
People will be talking about the same thing, hop hopefully not, but you know, two thousand and one hundred and eighty or something.
If we if we last that long if we last that long.
That's true.
Your paintings are absolutely beautiful.
I know this is a holography show but I have to comment to let people also visit you know the web pages that you have for your paintings.
Thanks.
They're gorgeous.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I I've uh I've really been spending a lot of time I think the last ten years has really been painting and uh again high realism and and uh and that's I think I talk about the same thing illusion, you know whether it's uh illusions of re of the world we live in right now.
So it's political and personal I guess.
Very it's becoming more and more political.
I think these shows both especially the one down near Washington it's become very political for me.
Yeah.
Would I be correct in saying that the um the difference that I notice between your paintings and your the work that you've done with holography is that the holography seems to have a a darker emotional tint to it?
Uh um yes.
Yeah, I think so.
Um I think the paintings are pretty dark as well.
I think everything the paintings have gotten a lot darker since two thousand.
Why do you think that is?
It's the world we live in.
Okay.
Yeah, you know.
I um uh two well the the show with the show in New York shelf s shelf life is really also um a look at you know, I'm sixty two years old and it was sort of an inventory of where I am right now and what I what I've done and what I haven't done.
And um uh and um that's the darkness I think, you know, it's just here we are, we live in the same age of uh accumulation and greed, you know, and there's war going on yet.
So um This was supposed to be the age of Aquarius, if I remember right.
I'm not too far behind you in age.
Yeah, yeah.
And uh I came up uh I left the States in nineteen sixty seven.
I hustle with a draft dodger.
So I'm an uh I'm an American expatriate.
I still have my Americ US citizenship.
Uh and I've been uh you know, involved in that ever since.
Yeah.
It it hasn't it hasn't changed.
It's gotten worse.
So yeah.
Well, I think in the sixties that's one of the things I've been thinking about a lot is is what we thought we could accomplish, you know.
We thought we were gonna change the world, right?
And uh here we are.
Um so the paintings in in the still lifes have been a l a lot getting a lot darker.
A lot of them are about accumulations and uh all my objects.
I don't know if you noticed in the some of the ones I put up on the website for the Maryland show, um all the objects are sort of on the edges and lot there's a lot of fear in 'em.
Um you have a few repeating themes in some of your paintings like string.
Uh you know, which goes over to the holograms as well, you know dice.
Yeah.
Number of paintings.
Have dice in them.
What what did that what does that represent or is that something that you prefer to just let the viewer interpret.
No, it's I think it started all I was when I was doing uh the ones you saw in New York, the Vanitas paintings, the Dutch still life, they used a lot of symbols of mortality.
Dice are dice are s is symbolic of fate as is a deck of cards say um I use I found one one thing I really like with the rubber band.
I have a lot of things tied up.
Uh whether it's vegetables, you know uh you'll see you'll see that a lot rubber band.
Strings are then sort of a a same thing.
Uh it's tension basically.
So there might be just a loose rubber band laying on in the foreground or the rubber band's gonna be wrapped around a bunch of vegetables.
So it's it represents in some way how we're all we're all bound up and you know, we're not free.
So you'll see a lot of those little symbols watches, you know, time again as well.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So just to remind us of our mortality.
When I would see one of the paintings for instance of the you know, vegetables being tied up.
To me it was a counter with vegetables tied up and here it has all this meaning behind it that I didn't get when I viewed it.
And now people can hear the meaning behind it and becomes more meaningful to them when they see it.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh well I hope you know, it it's it's nice when it comes through I think they come through on different levels.
I mean you can either look at something on the surface and you know, so it's it's a nice looking pair, but um uh you also have this other deeper meanings behind it, you know.
So I think that's how I've always tried to do my work even with holography.
You know, you can look at it in in different ways.
Well pain painting is very representative and holography is very real.
I mean the object that you do is uh of holography, th that's what it is.
Uh how do you make the switch from one to the other and and sometimes even combine them?
Well, I th I I think of painting as that's an illusion um of two dimensionality.
I'm I take a real object and I make a two dimensional illusion of it.
And with holography I'm just making a three dimensional.
You're just adding that element of space.
Um It was an interesting show that I had in the eighties with another artist here in the uh Lehigh Valley of Pennsylvania and they combined me with an artist that took three dimensional objects and painted them in such a way that they became flat.
And then they had my holograms there, which was a flat surface that showed three dimensions.
I thought that was a nice pairing.
That's very nice.
Yeah, I like that idea.
I think that's what that's what I've played with a lot as well.
I like I like going between mediums in that way, you know.
Um yeah.
Yeah, I think y yeah, well, some place on your one of your websites you said something about you didn't you didn't just do objects to represent objects.
Yeah.
I try not to.
Y you know, I I I agree with you completely there.
You know, it has to be something more.
I mean and why why make a hologram of something?
There has to be a reason.
What is holography gift to that object?
Mm-hmm.
And and to me it's it's been uh number one transparency.
I don't usually back the holograms.
I like to make 'em as bright as possible so they're transparent.
And then if they're floating behind the glass then I can put other objects within that same volume.
So so two objects can occupy the same space.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh which is not possible to do in any other media.
Exactly.
You know, so that's w that's where then you beat photography, you know you know it's so you're not you're not just replicating an object.
With you gotta do something else with it.
Without moving on to technology, your glass must be e holographic plates must be extremely clear.
I I remember seeing one of yours with uh a a light bulb and a figurine that sort of reconstructs in the light bulb.
But it almost seems like a a clear piece of cover glass rather than a hologram that's in front of you I've I wish I knew I I have no idea how I did those.
It was a series I did.
Um I think I was using Doris Villa's lab in New York.
And I and I didn't know much about holography and I the only thing I could figure out is possibly that I really had my exposure times really low or or the developing times really low, which is something that I didn't get all that noise on the glass.
Yeah.
And I haven't been able to replicate it since.
You know, well I mean I haven't really taken the time in all fairness to play around with it that much anymore.
But uh but yeah, I haven't gotten that.
I mean I tried uh I tried uh oh uh taking some transfers and then uh bleaching 'em out and things like this, you know, that whole but that doesn't do anything.
You just dim the image.
Yeah.
So yeah, I wish I could I I'll figure that out again someday, hopefully.
But that worked with D Doris Villa, was that the Hope Street series?
That's right.
Yeah.
They're interesting is little torsos.
Then I had those floating.
So then you could put a photograph behind it and then the image would look like it's floating through or like I had photos of windows and things and uh it would float right through the image.
I like your memento.
Yeah.
Oh good.
Is that object or is that a photograph?
Uh 'cause the objects that you've used, if it is a photograph, it it looks very three dimensional.
I think there's a key hanging.
There's a few other pieces of combination of both.
Yeah.
Uh very you know, very uh the depth maybe was only about an inch on that one.
Just a very shallow depth behind the behind the hologram.
Yeah.
So I had the again the hologram was the window in these little boxes.
And then I put um fo photographs and uh oh, just bits and pieces.
Yeah.
It was very successful in the in that the images do create feelings within I'm not sure if the feelings that I have would be the same feelings as someone else, but you know, especially the memento I felt quite a bit of of tension and almost uh gasping for breath.
Oh really?
You know, and in that piece there.
Well that was a that was a little strange when I had also a photo in there of uh of my mother's my mother my when my mother died, uh she sort of the week before she died she let us know that our grandfather wasn't really our grandfather and she had been illegitimate and it was this little secret she was hiding and she came out with this photo of uh of what who she thought was her real father and he was a German soldier from World War One.
And uh so there was this image I you know I put that in there of this little German soldier in the background.
Yeah.
And it was yeah, so may you know there was a lot of feeling in that one I guess.
It was all parts of my mother.
The key from the house in Ohio, the old farm.
I think objects have um uh objects have little lives of their own sometimes I think everything has a life of its own, even a rock.
Yeah, yeah.
You know.
And we're all connected to it.
Yep.
That's holography in a nutshell really.
Even thought.
People think that thought is something separate from the universe that surrounds us, but thought is an integral part of the universe and it falls under the same laws of the universe.
Which means you can attract to you whatever it is that you're thinking about.
And that happens to a lot of people.
This is this is another idea that I w that when I started doing this show for New York, the Shelf Life series, it's involved right now I'm working a lot of with digital transparencies and uh and then putting objects within the digital transparencies in the same way that I would use the holograms.
But the idea had occurred, you know, this whole business with Iraq I was really and thinking of my own what what's my own responsibility for this, you know, and uh yeah we all are because we're all part of the world, you know.
We're all consumers.
We all bought into the stock market.
And um in the same way that, you know, you're saying we're all all the objects in the world.
You know, when someone dies there, we're affected.
We're all part of the same uh atomic structure.
Yeah.
It's like a sphere.
Yeah, yeah.
We're it it's we live in if we you know if we live in a global society we're gonna have to accept some responsibility for all these things that are happening too.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Sometimes I've I have hopeful thoughts about that and other times it's like you know maybe it's just the nature of the beast.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is I I've always been fairly optimistic.
Mm-hmm.
But I just had a grandchild this summer.
Oh congratulations.
And that's you know, you really start thinking, you know, what are we doing?
And uh maybe this is something different, you know.
Anyway.
That and the fact I've got a really bad cold so uh Yeah I got your email about that.
I was going to see if you were okay later tonight and then just you know see if you wanted to do it tomorrow but today's great.
You sound good.
You sound in good spirits.
Oh always I'm nearly finished with all this shipping and sending uh uh work to the show so I can uh I'm gonna go off to my cabin for a couple of days and sit in the sun.
That's nice.
You have sun You don't yet?
We we just had ice and snow and it's still winter's hanging on, you know?
No no no we had the ice and snow last week.
Today's the first day of sun.
Oh, okay.
Well maybe uh we'll have the same luck here.
When was the last time you were working with philography.
Has it been a few years for you?
Yeah, yeah.
Really?
I haven't uh well I did.
I think I you know after the work you saw in two thousand I went to the Hollow Center, I think it was two thousand three.
I had this I had a series of um more optics I was doing and I had built these ceramic uh uh call them retired generals.
They were just um jesters uh you know parody on Bush I guess and uh the shots just weren't that great.
My masters weren't that great so my transfers weren't that great and kinda I didn't really do any more with those and so I haven't done anything since.
But uh I notice you're doing some work with um with uh digital yet.
Yeah, little L C D panels.
Yeah yeah and they're very inexpensive now.
You know they're what?
They're very inexpensive.
That interests me.
Yeah and they hook right onto the back of your computer.
They work like your monitor does.
In fact you can plug your monitor into them so that you can see what it is you're working on while the L C D panels on the table.
Wow.
Yeah.
Should look into it.
Or you know send me an email I'll send you some information about it.
Well y I notice you use um you do a lot with uh Photoshop and photo transparencies.
That's what I've been doing.
And then I started doing some photo etching using uh uh material called image on and uh using the sun to to develop oh okay uh the plates onto this f uh uh material and then doing some photo etching and I actually got a print a few photo prints in the New York show with uh but um the L C D that sounds interesting.
But you uh do you ever make digital po uh positive transparencies?
Have you tried that rather than just film?
Digital positive transparencies rather than the film.
No, I have not done that.
I have not done that.
The Um i it's it seems I don't know, it's been working for me to do the photo um transfers, but uh I don't know if it would work.
Yeah.
I would probably have to outsource the output of those files to get, you know, uh good gradation of tone.
And things like that rather than rely on.
It's the output device.
I just have a a little printer.
Yeah.
And I don't think the printer is capable of of giving me the uh tonal gradations that you know I would have on the screen, you know.
Yeah, you're probably right.
Yeah.
Those stuff I've been just using a little inkjet printer and um and uh I'd at least have to do something later anyway.
But they're I think it would be fine for line art.
You know, line art would be fine.
Well I I no I d I I should show you um I should show you uh one of the prints I did do from one of the paintings and I did it in black and white.
And it goes on to a Mylar inkjet like it goes on to Mylar?
Yeah I just use uh I just use uh overhead transparency paper from Staples and you just start playing around with it.
You know?
Uh you can just you can download so many different curves.
You just have to keep it really light.
Mm-hmm.
I think you know like twenty percent off of what your normal uh you know do a reversal in Photoshop and then uh and then maybe lighten it up by about twenty percent and try you know you can screen it.
I think you have to screen it too and that's where it you know the dots you know where you have to be careful if you're doing multiple exposures that you don't get more ray patterns you know using the dots on multiple exposures too.
Yeah.
Anyway.
I'm yeah, I'm I'm curious about this L C D uh work you're doing.
Yeah.
Well, any time you want to talk about it, you know, as a side note, be happy to uh maybe have to it go sit down with a cup of tea and uh give me a call or something.
Oh that'd be great, yeah.
Yeah.
Anything that you would say to any art students out there?
You know, that might be thinking, you know, let me give this a try.
What would you say to them?
Do it, you know.
I mean which holography or painting or holography, yeah.
Because uh I would think that a lot of art students would go into it thinking that they're gonna wind up on the cover of uh art today or even something like newsweek or something, but that's the problem.
That's not the reality.
Uh well, n uh from what I hear that's the problem with a lot of uh professions.
I mean it's uh what the kids think well I that's a generalization in some ways.
Yeah.
I'm not making a lot from my paintings either.
So I'm I'm trying some prints now.
Yeah.
Holography, I don't know.
You know more about you know, you you can do it.
You can do it cheaper than I could.
But uh Why why do you think that is?
Uh if I wanted to get back into holography, I would probably do it that way.
I'd get myself a little diode laser and uh sand table.
Yeah.
Do it that way.
Um otherwise it gets too discouraging, you know, having to go through uh trying to get funding or whatever.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't get grants.
I don't know.
I've never had a grant.
No?
If I ever ha if I ever needed money for a box of thirty by forty centimeter plates or something, I'd find extra work to do and go out and do it and make the money.
I've never had a grant.
Yeah.
Well, in you know, so you've probably done a lot more work than a lot than than a lot of people I know who who won't do something because they haven't gotten the grant.
Yeah, I don't know what the I mean everyone has their own mindset towards things, but uh I don't rely on very many external things other than you know, myself sometimes.
You know, to that's the way to live.
Yes, it's independent, you know, I guess.
Well, we're coming up on twenty seven minutes.
Is there anything that you wish we had talked about that we didn't?
You know considering the audience, of course, you know, we've got school kids that listen to this in their computer labs at school.
You've got scientists that are listening to it that are, you know, physicists and optical engineers, you've got hobbyists, you have You know, I I don't think it makes I think anybody that has just a passion for what they do.
Uh you know, it doesn't matter whether whether you're an artist or a scientist or I mean a school kid can make just as good art as an artist can.
You know?
Yeah.
If you're just if you're creative and y and you know, you're looking for something to say to say basically, either about yourself or about the world we live in, you know.
And I think we're living in a time when when a lot more people should be talking about hey, there's something going wrong with the world we're living in.
Mm-hmm.
And don't be afraid to to speak up.
Yeah, in whatever way you can.
Yeah, exactly.
And it might be a simple thing like taking an image or that really moves you, you know.
I mean I use I I got some images from the internet uh that I used in a lot of my photo transparencies.
It was this little image of the helicopters.
Mm-hmm.
Uh little black hawk helicopters.
I've got 'em floating through jars and floating through tiles and and uh you know, it was just it's something that just speaks to me of uh symbolic of the destruction of the world right now.
Yeah.
And um so I use that and I use the glass jar, you know.
The ball jar.
The ball jar, right.
Yeah.
I love that jar.
I don't know what it is about it.
The symmetry, the the fragility, it's just it just it's become a container, you know.
And well that's that's what I think artists are or art is, you know.
We're all containers for bigger things.
You I wonder if you would be s I wonder if you would be surprised at how many people that are listening to this have no idea what we're talking about when we say a ball jar.
Really?
Oh sure.
Is that typically um Ohioan, I think a ball jar?
Oh no, I don't think so.
I think it's more generational.
Uh I think chronologically.
Chronologically, yeah.
Yeah.
We have all the farmers markets here to get fresh produce and Oh you c you go uh I had I was looking for some images of uh I I've got a lot of glass jars.
Um actually uh and two of them I got from my mother from the thirties.
They were used to uh canned apple butter.
And they had a great pattern in it.
I made a couple holograms of uh of that pattern in the jars.
But um uh th they're collector's items now.
I mean it's collecting ball jars if you ha Google it and you'll see all the different kind of glass you know.
Yeah.
There's some f ball jar fanatics, I'm sure.
I have bicentennial ball jars.
It's got uh seventeen seventy six to nineteen seventy six on the ball jar.
Isn't that right?
I didn't realize if you ever have use for something like that, let me know.
I'll put it in a box and send it to me.
Well the the one the one jar that I've been using I I think it's a yeah it's a ball mason jar.
And under underneath it it says perfect mason.
Mm in those in those uh letters that stand out, you know what are you trying to say on on the jar, you know, and they catch the light.
So I've painted a couple of that trying to perfect mason.
Yeah I love your replica work.
Of the what is it a door a barn door or something?
Pardon?
Is it a barn door or something or what is it was a door I found in um the garbage in Toronto on my street.
Somebody had thrown it out probably What a piece of work that isn't that nice.
Yeah.
That that intrigues me more than uh anything I believe.
For some reason it's just uh that's that's I th I think that particular piece was really the basis for a lot of my that was the basis for painting originally.
I thought well what's the difference if I just copy something, you know and uh and then I realized you know I so I painstakingly replicated this six foot door, five foot you know, I've still got this piece.
And uh I did it sort of square by square.
I would s you know match completely match in in color and everything and then when I put these things standing side by side, you know, I there was something that happened.
Mm-hmm.
You know.
That that's the be that's there's something in illusion, you know.
There's something in the crack between the reality and illusion.
Or the real object and the illusionary object.
Yeah.
That says something.
I'm not I'm not sure what.
But it it's it's whether it's that next dimension or whatever, you know.
Well in this in this day of uh biotechnology and cloning it's uh an interesting piece as well.
Yeah.
You know, I have to come back to um uh I come back I come through your way actually quite a bit, 'cause I You do?
Well, I visit my sister out in Washington.
Oh, you should give me a call.
I worked at Georgetown Hospital for a while.
Okay.
I like that area.
Yeah, oh yeah.
We've I go through Antietam and all those places around there.
The battlefields.
Yeah.
Anyway.
So I I'll stop by sometime anyway.
We'll be in touch.
Okay.
All right.
Take care, have a good weekend.
You too.
Bye.